your contract has not been extended
then maybe you have
entitled to an extra monthly salary from your employer
that is the case
in the netherlands we have the notification obligation
that is an obligation that an employer has
to the staff
what it wants to get rid of and the contract
does not want to renew
to clarify this
if your employer intends
not to renew your contract
then he should at least do this to you
let us know a month in advance
it must be clear
you must be able to understand
and it must be in writing
if your employer doesn't do this
then he has to pay you a fee for this
some kind of compensation
and that compensation is equal to 1 month's salary
or an average thereof
if your employer has informed you
but just too late
for example two weeks in advance
instead of a month
then you will also receive that compensation proportionally
of the amount your employer was late
so suppose your employer is two weeks late
then you do not get a monthly salary
but the average salary of two weeks
a nice extra if your contract is not renewed